welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins i've been sitting in
for david pakman today
and we've got a lot more to cover and
not a lot of time to do it so let's jump
back in
let's go back to afghanistan actually
where donald trump jr on twitter has
been accused of gloating
over the fact that the taliban has
overtaken this country
in a series of different tweets
trump jr
has either laughed
about what's happening
or
he has directly said well this isn't
surprising and actually gone on to
attack the military itself the u.s
military uh here's a sampling of some of
these tweets one of them said not
surprising biden's woke intelligence
gurus are the same ones who were wrong
on russia collusion and russian bounties
wrong about china and iran being
competitors wrong on covet origins wrong
on hunter's laptop and wrong on
basically everything else
hunter's laptop hunter's laptop holy wow
that's something i don't think anybody
has really thought about in a long time
except of course for the grifters who
believe that pushing that idiotic story
uh was gonna do something for him
remember when tucker carlson told us
that he actually you know they they had
like the contents of it and he sent it
to himself and then oh it got lost in
the mail oh no
wha what what a non-story that
republicans and again the grifters were
pushing so hard
that just
disappeared
when they realized there was nothing
there and they never made apologies for
it
but i guess donald trump jr is still
fuming
about hunter's laptop
what an idiot
not to mention woke intelligence
committee what what what does that what
does that even mean
can anybody explain to me what that
means and how it would have an impact
on
the taliban retaking afghanistan because
i'm at a loss for that
i i really cannot connect those two dots
but of course that's republicans today
right
you got to throw
woke people into every talking point you
have whether it fits or not you just
shoehorn it in there
and people might take you seriously this
is ridiculous
um he goes on in another tweet here and
this was actually in response to
something the u.s embassy in kabul had
uh tweeted out just days ago
calls for peace and he tweeted out lol
this is real
lol laugh out loud
laughing out loud really
we have people
so desperate to flee the country they're
getting run over by airplanes
on the runway at the airport
and this dude's just like lol
what a scumbag
he also attacked the u.s embassy in
kabul where from where officials were
airlifted to safety on sunday for
tweeting in support of lgbt rights in
june because they quote
should have focused on other things but
who knows i'm sure the media will tell
us they're doing great
so he went back and found a tweet from
june
where they're talking about lgbtq
equality he said should have focused on
other things
again all i can say is what a scumbag
what an absolute pathetic piece of human
garbage
but that is what the trump family is
that is what donald j trump jr
is
gloating about what is happening in the
country of afghanistan even though
what's happening in afghanistan is
exactly
what his dad wanted done
your dad junior
wanted us to pull all the troops out of
afghanistan
but of course you know he didn't want it
to happen under his administration so
the deal he signed with the taliban was
oh yeah 14 months from now of course
he expected to be president by then and
if he had one of course this would still
be happening
because this is a failure of 20 years of
policy not seven
months
of joe biden
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a life saver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com slash
pacman